industrie du port actuellement connaît
une baisse importante du côté des
exportations donc de la consommation
internationale donc c'est certain qui va
devoir y avoir un ajustement du côté de
la production le gouvernement le gros
travail sur une aide financière pour les
éleveurs de porc mais le Premier
ministre souligne qu'il devrait y avoir
moins de production pour s'adapter au
marché mondial c'est dans ce contexte
que les principaux acteurs de
l'industrie porcine ont annoncé une
entente sur les prix aujourd'hui les
éleveurs ont accepté une baisse de prix
d'environ 4 et demi pour cent par
rapport à la moyenne des 10 dernières
années en échange ils auront droit à une
partie des bénéfices des transformateurs
principalement Olymel si l'industrie
connaît une reprise avec nous ce soir
Yannick Gervais le PDG de l'immeuble
bonsoir Monsieur Gervais bonsoir
Monsieur Fillon période quand même très
très difficile dans le secteur porcin
cette entente aujourd'hui elle change
quoi
en fait cette rentrée la première étape
c'est que adon quand même du temps on
parle quand même de ce qui était octroyé
par par les éleveurs il y a encore
beaucoup de choses à mettre en place au
niveau des usines vous l'avez mentionné
il y a beaucoup de turbulences au niveau
du marché mondial du côté du port du
côté de notre modèle d'affaires c'est
vrai pour les autres abattoires aussi au
niveau du Québec cette s'éloigner de la
commodité où on est sur un échiquier
mondial puis qu'on travaille pas
nécessairement avec les mêmes
contraintes que certains concurrents
outre-mer puis s'en aller vers un marché
vraiment plus axé sur la valeur ajoutée
donc des pièces des OC des pièces qui
sont emballées puis qui sont passionnés
pour nos clients donc pour faire ça ça
prend de la main d'oeuvre donc ça c'est
le plus gros point mais est-ce que ça
assure par exemple aux éleveurs de porcs
qui disaient récemment nous on peut plus
vivre avec des rabais on peut plus vivre
avec avec le prix qu'on nous donne
est-ce qu'on assure que tout le monde
sort gagnant aujourd'hui de ça vous
direz je pense que c'est des bases très
solides pour le long terme ça serait fou
de vous dire que demain matin autant
pour les éleveurs que pour nous tout est
gagné par contre c'est une attente
négociée une première de faire environ
15 ans donc je pense qu'on établit un
bon dialogue on établit une transparence
on ramène une confiance au niveau de la
filière donc je pense que c'est toutes
des bonnes bases mais je me répète non
la partie est pas gagné pour les
différents est-ce que ça veut dire que
votre restructuration chez alimail n'est
pas terminé qui pourrait y avoir encore
des compressions je vous dirais que de
notre côté là les plus grosses étapes
sont complétées je me plains à dire il y
a toujours place à de l'optimisation
mais pour nous cette réduction
d'avattage là parce que le climat ça a
culminé par la fermeture de l'abattoir
de Vallée Jonction mais c'est tout près
d'un million de pales nous qu'on aurait
dû donc on va réduire des nouveaux
abattages mais pour ça le pour nous là
on a atteint ce qu'on vivait comme
modèle d'affaires je vous mentionner au
niveau de la valeur ajoutée et de nos
activités de viande transformée les
quelques milles travailleurs devaient
les jonction est-ce que vous avez les
moyens contenus que vous avez quand même
fermé à peu près cinq installations si
je me trompe pas au cours des derniers
mois ou de la dernière année aux
dernières années est-ce que vous avez
les moyens de tous les relocaliser s'ils
le veulent ou effectivement on a on peut
les relocaliser on a plusieurs sites au
Québec on comprendra qui peut avoir
certaines contraintes pour des employés
des familles de se déplacer vers
d'autres sites au niveau de l'email mais
on est prêt à les accueillir on a encore
des besoins au niveau de la main
d'oeuvre pour pour maintenir notre plan
d'affaires avez-vous besoin d'aide
encore du gouvernement du Québec pour le
moment nous on est on a un plan
d'affaires qui est solide on s'est pris
en main on a opéré une optimisation de
restructuration donc pour le moment de
notre côté avec ses balises là on voit
l'avenir de façon beaucoup plus positive
le gouvernement qui a investi avec
Investissement Québec qui injecté 150
millions dans le capital de l'email en
2021 on n'est pas là on a quand vous
dites on n'est pas là puis on fait
confiance à notre plan est-ce que ça
vient exclure la possibilité de demander
à Québec d'injecter encore de l'argent
dans l'e-mail encore une fois pour le
moment nous avec ce qu'on a signé
aujourd'hui et puis avec le nouveau un
modèle d'affaires qui va prendre forme à
mesure le qu'on va on va réduire ses
abattages là pour nous là il y a pas de
demande formelle qui ont été faites
est-ce que les choix que vous avez fait
les décisions que vous avez prises de
multiplier par exemple les acquisitions
dans un moment où ça coûtait cher puis
on pense beaucoup au groupe Ménard en
2019 que vous avez racheté est-ce que
vous êtes responsable d'une partie des
problèmes que vous connaissez
je vous dirai que c'est quand même un
modèle à l'époque ou en tout cas un
environnement qui était excessivement
différent on était préparémis on parle
pas de l'inflation vous avez invoqué
d'entrée de jeu tout le volet du port au
niveau mondial c'était totalement
différent donc c'est une décision je
pense c'est une excellente décision une
excellent modèle une excellente
entreprise lors de l'acquisition par
contre là quand on le regarde avec du
recul et puis on n'avait pas personne de
boule de cristal à ce moment-là c'est
sûr que ça mène certaines pressions par
contre je le disais ça reste un modèle
hyper performant de côté
coup d'avoir multiplié les acquisitions
ce fut une mauvaise décision d'affaires
non moi je pense que au contraire on
regarde le Portefeuille de marque
aujourd'hui du côté de l'email je pense
c'est ce qui définit bien notre modèle
d'affaires on a fait des très belles
acquisitions au niveau de la valeur on a
des on a eu des niveaux records en
termes de revenus du côté de ce
secteur-là aussi la plupart des
acquisitions sont exclue Ménard était
justement dans des viandes transformées
avec un portefeuille de marque donc
je suis pas prêt à dire que ce fut de
mauvaise décision
ce qui vous affecte et ce qui vous amène
à faire des compressions comme vous
l'avez fait c'est essentiellement l'état
du marché c'est des éléments externes à
vous dites-vous mais je vous dirais que
deux éléments là où on peut voir on a eu
quand même un plan d'acquisition qui
était agressif une croissance qui a été
soutenue je vous le disais quand même
des belles marques qui ont été acquises
par contre ce qui a été peut-être un peu
reporté là c'est une année une
optimisation à faire on fait des
acquisitions il y a plusieurs actifs qui
avec ses acquisitions là donc c'est ce
qu'on a opéré dans les deux dernières
années justement d'optimiser ce modèle
là puis malheureusement
ça a été ça a été certaines fermetures
d'usine elle vous le mentionnez tantôt
on avait des sites qui étaient des
disposés accueillir accueillir ses
employés là puis on est tout de 50 % de
reclassement donc il y avait vraiment
quelque chose à optimiser au niveau au
niveau du portefeuille de Max c'est ça
doit délaisser une bonne partie de
l'exportation pour revenir à un modèle
davantage intérieur ou d'autosuffisance
je vous dirais que l'auto suffisance
serait une énorme coupure une énorme
réduction quand même là faut comprendre
que la consommation pas au Québec se
fait beaucoup par les produits
transformés aussi par les viandes les
viandes fraîches mais quand même un peu
moins que certains autres pays on aura
toujours besoin des marchés émergents le
pronom la chaîne ou autre par rapport à
tout ce qui est sous-produit je fais
souvent la blague même si je vous
donnais une tête de porc monsieur Filion
pour convaincu que vous auriez le goût
de la cuisiner donc on se doit de
valoriser
ces couples là par contre je le disais
là c'est de trouver une valeur ajoutée à
nos produits les rendre prêt à être
consommés les faire vraiment tout le
désossage qui permettrait aux gens de
bien le cuisiner donc on va garder les
marchés d'exportation mais des marchés à
valeur ajoutée comme le Japon comme la
Corée le où on est capable de bien
valoriser puis les gens sont prêts à
payer une prime pour la qualité du sport
québécois monsieur Gervais merci d'avoir
été avec nous ce soir merci Monsieur
Philippe bonne fin de soirée pour voir
nos émissions en entier rendez-vous sur
la chaîne ici RDI